I didn't get a tear.
You lift sap.
Yeah,
that's what I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna tear your eyes
out of the socket.
I'm gonna hit you,
and you're gonna fall,
so this is a scene that came out of a
nineties television show for children
that may be hard to believe,
but then again,
a lot of the scenes that came out of the
Ren and stimpy show pretty hard to
believe.
I'm a child of the nineties and no,
I haven't seen many of the episodes of
this show for well over a decade on
rewatching the series.
I was amazed by how much of the imagery
was lodged deep in my memory,
like the walls of tiers that welled up
and were ejected out of stimpy's eyes in
this episode called the little giant or
the nerve endings that were
excrutiatingly plucked out of Rennes gum
sockets.
And of course every gruesome yet
painterly,
extreme closeup that became a staple of
the show and a few that followed along
with the simpsons.
Ren and stimpy was a seminal cartoon of
the animation renaissance that hit TV in
the early 19 nineties.
Whereas the simpsons was focused on
sharp satirical writing,
Ren and stimpy and its creator John
Crikey Volusia.
We're obsessed with unique,
detailed and highly,
very animation techniques.
I think this is why the imagery of Ren
and stimpy really leaves a mark on your
brain.
Quick Volusia was coming from a
notorious starkey gene commercial
animation in which the production of
shows was fragment in an outsourced
overseas to places like Taiwan and the
Philippines.
Plotlines were simple cliche and facial
expressions were relegated to happy,
sad and confused,
and that's about it.
There's a million versions of happy and
sad and perplexed,
and then there's all these other kinds
of emotions that I've labeled,
but you can draw them.
I urged my artists all the time to never
draw an expression that they've drawn
before.
So you're not allowed.
Quickfire.
Lucy found his sensibility,
apprenticing and working cowork Ralph
Bash in animation legend who was
producing some of the only interesting
commercial work of the 19 seventies.
He married the surreal often disturbing
field bash key stuff with the dense
energetic style of Bob Clampett cartoons
of the 19 thirties and forties,
like Clampett,
quick flu seat.
Wanted Ren and snippy to be filled with
a new idea.
Every second,
we just take a look at these handful of
frames from what's probably the best
episode of the series,
stimpy's invention,
every frame.
It's a completely new drawing.
The scrip floozy once said of Clampett.
It doesn't even look like it animates
yet in real time.
It works perfectly.
It communicates a totally unique
emotion,
quick volusia his team or after with Ren
and stimpy,
two characters that actually got under
your skin to characters that were so
unique and dense in their movement and
speech that you had to see a soul in
them,
however twisted that Sol was,
and this quality has to be what makes
the show so disturbing to every slimy,
gunky,
sweaty Harry Wu's had an unnerving
reality and the show played on anxieties
about bodily fluids at a time when the
United States was at the height of its
fears about the aids.
Derek,
I believe that they should have separate
hospitals so that the people that have a
good go in there and not be in regular
hospitals but that day,
but
kids loved Ren and stimpy.
It had higher ratings in its first year
than fellow Nick toons,
Doug and regret's combined.
The creators maintained that they were
on the kids side,
spoonfed morals in school at home and on
just about every children's show,
animated or not.
Ren and stimpy offered lesson free,
Zany Gross,
ridiculous humor.
What quick flu see,
believe was the point of cartoons
anyway,
and escape parents groups protested the
show,
but the audience had spoken and indeed
in that first year at 35 percent of the
people who watched ren and stimpy were
over 18 years old.
MTV started rerunning the first season
at 7:00
PM instead of 11:00
AM viewing parties were arranged at
college campuses and for good reason,
like the adult swim cartoons that are in
many ways it's spawn.
Ren and stimpy mixed absurd character
driven action with sly parodies of
earlier cartoons,
satirical and sometimes treasonous gags.
Like when powdered toast man burned the
bill of rights in the constitution to
keep warm sexual innuendo that was off
the charts and just genuinely terrifying
moments.
The police,
Ren and stimpy didn't hold back on the
insanity of its characters.
Number of times.
Wren goes completely psychotic and the
honesty and quick for Lucy's voice
acting coupled with the manic animation,
including glaring abstract backgrounds
and sound effects,
is enough to pull the viewer into the
cartoon and into that palpable distress.
The creators of Ren and stimpy had
healthy disdain for the way cartoons had
aggressively commercialized and
commodified childhood with merchandise
as simple well as simple as a log log,
and they regretted that their peers were
forced feeding ethical norms to their
audiences on a weekly basis,
so they made a show that brilliantly
mocked these things,
but I don't think Crikey,
for Lucy's ultimate goal was to make
something for adults.
I think he wanted to create a show for
kids to marvel at something that yanked
your attention the way the old clampett
cartoons did something as dark and seedy
as the original fairytales,
but uproariously funny and inventive in
every frame to do this scrip flu seat,
push the system to its limits and was
eventually fired after the season.
The show went on,
but the richest episodes were during his
reign in 91 and 92.
The series masterpiece stimpy's
invention took a full year to produce.
Now maybe that was overkill,
but at the same time,
it's no doubt that obsessive attention
to detail that burned ren and stimpy
onto all of our brains
forever.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
My brain is complete mush after watching
a week of Ren simpy,
but it was so worth it.
It's genius genius show 'em.
Anyway,
follow me on twitter.
I never mentioned twitter on this end
screen,
but a lot of cool things are happening
there,
so follow me on twitter at the nerd
writer.
Subscribe if you haven't already and
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
People,
squarespace are just awesome.
You know they,
they,
they fund this channel,
they helped to fund it,
but they don't interfere in the content,
which is the ultimate for me.
So awesome.
They have a great product,
sleek,
intuitive,
awesome looking websites.
You don't have to know coding to make
one.
You do anything on there.
You sign up for a year.
I can get a free domain name,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Squarespace,
you should.
I will see you guys next Wednesday.